alrighty folks today we are going to
take a look at some of the most
woke tic toc clips out there now my
producers tell me these are particularly
difficult to watch but
i will be the judge you may regret that
before we begin i want to give a shout
out to giant partners for sponsoring
this video
qprosexual people are asexual people who
still desire a sexual relationship but
don't experience sexual attraction
qposexual people may decide to have a
sexual relationship despite not feeling
sexual attraction while others don't
both are completely valid and
communication is key hope i could help
check out my
vampire kid explains for more it did it
helped it helped
i now understand nothing about what just
happened how hard do we have to work to
come up with sexual minorities now right
we have such a
viciously intolerant brutal sexist
heteronormative
sex patriarchal society we have
alienated
so many people that they have to work so
hard to come up with being a member of a
sexual minority
that usage like a person who didn't want
to have sex but who sometimes has sex
how do you
exactly do you like identify into it and
sometimes you're into the sex you're no
longer cute biosexual but this is the
thing it's all fluid right you could be
whatever you want at any time
and no one has to verify any of this you
just declare yourself a sexual minority
i declare so
it's fun to watch how we have created
basically two categories in american
society the victimized
and the victimizers and when you create
those two categories
everybody wants to be in the victimized
category because you don't want to be a
victimizer so now you're like a
couposexual
or a demisexual was was the other one
that was those recently in the news
because of andrew cuomo's daughter
declaring herself
a woman who only wants to have sex with
people to whom she's emotionally
attracted which
used to just be called a woman but it's
all it's all good times you have terms
for everything now
terms up the wazoo governor abbott has
just lifted the mandatory mass mandate
in the entire state of texas
now businesses are back at 100 capacity
so when there's a giant spike in our
country
you're gonna know exactly who to blame
you could say don't mess with texas all
you want you know who can mess with
texas
the wrath of god viruses don't care
about your weird state pride get over it
did the spike happen
nope it did not also i i have a feeling
this
may be uh one of the only times this
person uses
god unironically it's funny how the left
will always talk about the wrath of god
when all they really mean is the sort of
pagan concept in which nature punishes
you for not being left-wing enough
this is healthy behavior oh my god other
people
aren't going to be mandated to wear
masks post
the possibility of vaccination and you
get a vaccine anytime you want
anybody can get one and i can't boss
people around god
will avenge himself on texas ah the most
religious people are the pagan atheists
hi i'm jax and i just came up with new
neopronouns that combine
he him she her and they them okay
so hear me out be them theirs okay they
them their whatever you want to consider
it right let's take the first one
d okay this combines she
he and they right they
that's what they said you know that's
what they said i don't know what you're
talking about
what are you talking about i don't know
what we're yelling about
also i mean just a refresher the word
the actually does have a meaning
right like v with two e's at the end
means you in english
so now you're just taking that term and
you've turned it not into they but also
into
they and he and also she and they
and him but not her that's another word
that's
thor's all of this is designed to
confuse all of this is designed to
convey less information
because as it turns out there is no
person who is male female and also
plural those people don't exist
plural nope not a thing
but uh well i mean i guess it's better
than those other neopronouns people are
calling themselves like unicorn
unicorn birds you know
we are a childish and foolish society hi
there my name is sarah
this little cutie is my son bennett as
you can see my son is a white male
so here are some books that i bought to
help prevent him from growing up to be
awful starting out strong we have c is
for consent um
pretty self-explanatory but it's a
picture book that goes into
detail about consent with your body with
family no thanks
because i'm raising a feminist we've got
a is for awesome 23
inspirational women finally we have
except when they don't a book about um
boys and girls liking whatever they want
regardless of their gender
oh sorry i'm just i'm looking up the
number for child protective services
this is a person who has a very clear
set of values that she wishes to impart
to her child
her set of values suggest that her son
being white and male
is naturally inclined toward being a
terrible horrible person and so she must
indoctrinate him to believe
that males and females are completely
fluid categories and also that white
males naturally are going to
be rapey seems like good times over
there but
here's the thing when you're a parent
you don't get to just bring up your
child like they're in a vacuum
you gotta pick a valley system so here's
a person picking a value system
and uh it has its downsides what are
your preferred pronouns
uh zazem oh i've never heard those
before what are they
uh they're what's known as neopronouns
what are
neopronouns they're basically your own
custom pronouns when no other pronouns
seem to fit
you come up with your own pronouns
anything can really be a pronoun
it's true how do i use them um it
depends
on the person and their pronouns zazem
follows a similar spelling to they in
them
and even similar grammar rules like
zerenzair
so zay zem zem self zers
things like that okay now you just sound
like an actor from 1940s doing a bad
german accent
what do they say have you talked to them
would you care for another schnitzel
neo pronouns are just you're making
is what i'm getting from this and we're
all supposed to just pretend this is
normal oh my god we're just supposed to
pretend that we're all we're gonna go
along with this now like okay
i just uh you know i i just felt so you
know marginalized by
typical human language that i've created
a new set of terms
in which i prefer to be referred to as
and also and also those are my new
pronouns so every time i come in the
room i want someone to say well
instead of like there he goes be there
we are taking all of the things like
reason
and human language it used to be
universal
and humanizing and we are removing those
in favor of just
random good times good times we'll get
to more of this
tick tock brilliance in just one second
first every company strives to have
unique values and a long lasting impact
we built our entire business around that
notion which is why we take data
incredibly seriously it's time to
position your company as an industry
leader create buzz attract new customers
and generate consistent revenue the
folks who can help you do that
giant partners they're america's number
one data driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space offering a variety of
business marketing solutions such as
database marketing brand development web
design
seo lead generation digital marketing
services as well as ad placement that's
just to name a few
of the things that they do whether you
own a small family business or handle
millions of bucks in revenue every year
giant partners can help you get to the
next level their marketing strategies
are research driven they are equipped
with 20 years of data experience
don't take my word for it their largest
customers include bmw nationwide ohio
state university
3m and ethan allen so head on over to
giantpartners.com right now to get your
business set up today again this
giantpartners.com
let them know that we sent you here at
the ben shapiro show head on over to
giantpartners.com right now
a one a two a three a four
one ounce of girt pride one ounce of
good pride
one one diary gender fluid
trans men and women too
trans men and women too wow first of all
just the musical
talent on display is spectacular
the hijacking of children into this
video is also particularly spectacular i
really did enjoy that non-binary gender
fluid trans men
and trans women too ah extraordinary
femininity demonstrated by this
particular trans woman definitely
convinces me that that gender is nothing
but a social
construct my fur girl just came up to me
and asked if she could play with my
dumbo trump flag
and i said my dumbo trump flag i don't
have one of those
and yeah she calls him dumbo i just
never corrected her
and she goes yeah you do this one
and i feel like it's kind of profound
did he ruin the flag for anybody else
just me um maybe you should have exposed
her to the american flag before donald
trump did that would have been your
solution right there
maybe the reason that she associates the
flag with trump is because you never
taught her what an american flag was
and that one's on you that one's on you
when it comes to inclusive language
oftentimes people tend to use phrases
like
people with penises or people with
vaginas rather than saying male and
female are men and women
while this can absolutely be inclusive
for trans people unfortunately it's not
always the most inclusive language for
intersex people
my advice is to use language that
focuses on function and not just
form that means focusing on the actual
function that you're talking about
such as people who can get pregnant
people who can get other people pregnant
people who are at risk of testicular
cancer and so on and so forth
this is much more inclusive because
there are intersex people who are born
with the vagina but don't have a uterus
or ovaries or an ability to menstruate
this is because some people that are
born of the penis don't have testes
i think that from now on we should
describe people by all of their
biological features
all of them so i think it should just
get longer and longer so it could be a
person
with a penis but no testes and also a
uterus but a prostate like
i feel like that would be better than
just saying intersex people honestly i i
wonder how many intersex people really
feel bad if you say that
they are an intersex person because that
is a biological status but
isn't what they identify as the only
thing that matters
why are we even trying to use objective
metrics like whether they are a person
who has a uterus
in order to measure who they truly are
inside this lady's too intolerant
wait sorry this this person who i
presume to have
a uterus but have to make an assumption
about i think this person
gender offender bender i've got what
they call gaydar
is um not sensitive enough frankly
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen if you start believing that
you're the hottest
alive here's what i don't like about
that statement why do you want to say
hottest instead of just hot
it's a superlative that implies
competition
is it because you're still basing your
self-worth on how you compete
with other hot aka women
just stop using super hot days this is
the stupidest
thing that i've seen in at least the
past 12 seconds yes it turns out that
life is filled with competition
it is well known by virtually every
social science study that there is
competition for mates
it's true in evolutionary biology and so
that composition
does exist and you can either pretend it
doesn't exist or you can recognize that
it does exist
but uh this person seems very very angry
about superlatives which makes them the
craziest
person that i've seen in the last few
seconds at least because i'm watching
these videos back to back and frankly i
just want to
run directly like screaming through a
playglass window
they're more how many of these are there
you're gonna like clockwork orange me
here and just pry my eyes open
uh guess what my patience is run
out
pansexuality is not inherently
biphobic they are both valid sexualities
both of them and while yes i have seen
pansexual people use that label for
questionable reasons they pretty quickly
get it once you explain things to them
they do if you took all that energy you
spend calling people biphobic and saying
they're performing by erasure and just
educated them there would be less
biphobia
there would be less by erasure because
you've explained it
and people will know the difference i
have had it with you guys
jesus what was that
i don't wha was that was that in in
human english
i don't know what any of that means you
know why this person's yelling at me
i don't know why you guys are putting me
through this i don't know why i employ
you
i'm surrounded by there's so
many things i'm i'm
so confused about and and troubled about
right now i think the only thing that we
can take away from
this particular video is that no one
should ever
use tick tock for any reason thank you
not only is it a chinese propaganda tool
gathering all your data
but also it's filled with self-obsessed
people
who believe that what they have to say
is very important no matter how stupid
or minut or ridiculous with that said if
you want to see me react to more insane
tech talks apparently let me know in the
comments or something
if you have any tick tocks you'd like me
to see you can share below and my
producers i am sure will check and then
torture me with those